[Música]
hola bienvenidos a la revista digital
donde abordamos los temas más
importantes del ciberespacio las redes
sociales y los medios de comunicación de
américa latina y el mundo la invasión de
rusia a ucrania ha hecho correr ríos de
tinta en todo el mundo sin embargo la
cobertura mediática se ha visto limitada
especialmente en territorio ruso con
detenciones de periodistas censura en
medios independientes y una retórica de
cadenas estatales que tratan de
justificar la guerra esto llevó a los
países europeos a evitar a estos medios
pero además la cobertura en occidente ha
sido objeto de críticas por algunos
comentarios racistas aquí les contamos
empezamos
en los países de europa ya no es posible
sintonizar los grandes medios estatales
rusos como 'russia today' más conocido
como rt y tampoco sputnik al menos no se
podrán ver a través de los medios de
transmisión tradicionales esta medida
también afecta a sus filiales en inglés
alemán y español la unión europea tomó
la decisión como represalia la invasión
de rusia a ucrania y argumentando que
estos medios son una máquina de
propaganda del gobierno ruso para
manipular la información
al suspender las actividades de
transmisión de sputnik y right day damos
un paso importante contra esta operación
de manipulación y cerramos el grifo de
los medios controlados por el estado
ruso en la unión europea en tiempos de
guerra las palabras importan estamos
presenciando propaganda masiva y
desinformación sobre este escandaloso
ataque a un país libre e independiente
no permitiremos que los apologistas del
kremlin viertan sus mentiras tóxicas que
justifican la guerra de putin o siempre
en las semillas de la división nuestra
unión en concreto significa que su señal
no estará disponible en televisión por
cable satélite y menos a través de redes
sociales aplicaciones y páginas web
google dijo que prohibir a la venta de
publicidad a través de sus plataformas
en rusia también bloqueó los canales 7 y
sputnik en youtube en toda europa y les
prohibió monetizar sus contenidos en el
resto del mundo además detuvo las
descargas de las aplicaciones de rt en
google play en territorio ucraniano
facebook también bloqueó el acceso a rt
y sputnik en los países de la unión
europea en instagram el contenido o los
contenidos se han visto restringidos en
twitter algunos usuarios en europa
reportan no tener acceso a las cuentas
mientras que otros todavía pueden
acceder a ellas víctor dijo que tomaría
medidas similares
de acuerdo con el equipo editorial de
sputnik la medida obedece a un antiguo
impulso de las autoridades europeas por
depurar un punto de vista diferente al
suyo
por su parte rt en francia- mencionó que
la prohibición a su cadena es una total
contradicción con los principios de
libertad de prensa y derecho a la
información
esta decisión constituye un precedente
peligroso para la libertad de expresión
en francia- y para el acceso de los
ciudadanos a la información completa
pero también el acceso de los europeos a
una pluralidad de puntos de vista sobre
las noticias nacionales e
internacionales y esto en un momento
importante de la historia de europa y el
mundo y mientras estos medios reclaman
libertad de expresión rusia ha decidido
tomar medidas similares en su territorio
en contra de medios y plataformas
occidentales el regulador de
comunicaciones ruso bloqueó twitter y
facebook y los sitios web de la cadena
británica bbc la alemana deutsche welle
y la estadounidense voice of america
entre otros la razón según dijo es la
propagación de lo que considera
información falsa de hecho la bbc
suspendió temporalmente el trabajo de
sus periodistas en rusia luego de que el
parlamento de este país aprobara por
unanimidad un proyecto que criminaliza
la difusión que rusia considera informe
falso
y es que describir la situación en
ucrania se ha convertido en un tema
delicado en rúsia el regulador de
comunicaciones ordenó a los medios
publicar únicamente informes oficiales
del gobierno sobre el conflicto en
ucrania y además está prohibido que
éstos mencionen las palabras guerra
ofensiva o invasión y que por el
contrario se le llame operación especial
u operación militar tal como lo vemos a
continuación en el canal de youtube de
rt la cadena se ha referido de esta
forma al lanzamiento de la ofensiva de
rusia y así lo vemos también en la
página web de sputnik el mensaje que
envían es que moscú está tratando de
defender a su propio pueblo contra la
agresión y la persecución impulsada por
occidente en ucrania
los medios independientes rusos son los
que se han visto más afectados nóvaya
gazeta cuyo director ganó el premio
nobel de paz el año pasado dijo que
eliminaría material sobre las acciones
militares rusas en ucrania después de
que escalarán las amenazas primero les
habían advertido que cerrarían no
bloquearían sus publicaciones y ahora
amenazan con enjuiciar a periodistas el
eco de moscú la principal estación de
radio independiente del país y uno de
los últimos medios liberales y más
respetados decidió cerrar tras las
presiones sobre su cobertura en la
guerra 2 una de las principales
estaciones de televisión independientes
de rusia anunció que suspendería sus
operaciones luego de que su sitio fuera
bloqueado como parte de la censura
decenas de periodistas independientes
han sido arrestados desde que inició la
ofensiva según informó el comité para la
protección de periodistas
algunos medios de comunicación de
occidente no han estado libres de
críticas y han sido acusados de racismo
por los polémicos comentarios que han
hecho sus periodistas en el terreno
durante el cubrimiento de la guerra y
que estaría normalizando el conflicto en
otras partes del mundo veamos algunos
ejemplos mientras hablaba del éxodo de
cientos de miles de ucranianos que
buscan refugio en otros países la
corresponsal de la estadounidense en
bici news que el ico biela dijo que
estos nuestros refugiados decir ya que
estos son refugiados de ucrania son
cristianos son blancos son muy parecidos
a la gente que vive en polonia también
en suelo polaco la corresponsal del
noticiero británico itv lucy watson dijo
que lo impensable le ha sucedido al
pueblo de ucrania y que esa no era una
nación en desarrollo del tercer mundo
sino europa y hablando de los ataques
rusos charly de agatha corresponsal de
la cadena estadounidense cbs news en
kiev dijo que este lugar refiriéndose a
la capital no era como irak o afganistán
y que por el contrario era una ciudad
relativamente civilizada donde no se
esperaría que algo así sucediera
hasta aquí y revista digital recuerde
que si quiere repetir esta u otra
emisión de nuestro programa lo puede
hacer a través de nuestra página web www
france24 puntocom
[Música]